this is my easy sushi recipe
because it's birthday season in my house
and the birthday boy requested it
and on top of organising all his presents
baking an elaborate cake and putting on a
party for him and all his mates
of course I also have time to source
all of the right ingredients
and prepare everybody's own personal favourite sushi
and that's my story and I'm sticking to it
and funnily enough it's also birthday season at St Pierres
they're turning 40 and to celebrate
they're giving away 40,000 pieces of sushi
on October 1st from 11:00am
and you don't even need to buy anything
you can just roll on up and get some free sushi
their key ingredients coming direct from Japan
alongside locally sourced items such as the
New Zealand King Salmon
the food is phenomenal so get your free sushi
pop it on a plate, hide the evidence
and your family will be none the wiser